es-tu prêt pour l'enfer absolu ouais
dans les pancakes sans soja tu ne
mangeras jamais hé il est notre délicieux ils ont l'air
vraiment bien genre de petit logo de soeur
avait l'air un petit paquet triste oh il est un
peu triste je vais le rendre heureux
disons  moi tu manques quelque chose parce que je suis très
surpris si tu fais euh mr.  Hauser d'accord,
vous savez ce qu'il n'y a pas de sirop d'érable, mais nous
avons du beurre de cajou mmm incroyable aujourd'hui mmm
tellement bon qu'ils sont même bons
sans mais je vais l'essayer avec voir
comment nous pensons que c'est un délice ouais
bon bon très bon nous sommes  bon ça vous a
manqué vous avez même manqué le beurre dans le
lait terrible c'est tellement bon
ici dans ma bouche je pense que terrible est un
mot extrême je pense qu'ils sont
défiés mais c'est un très bon effort
qui ne sait pas si les graines de lin ne l'ont pas fait
faites du bon travail les graines noires pour remplacer
est celle que vous avez l'huile de noix de coco mais nous
n'en avions pas et ce n'est tout simplement pas bien
vous n'aviez pas les bons ingrédients d'
accord c'est ce que je pense que nous aurons un
deuxième tour d'accord  vous obtenez tous les bons
ingrédients je vais faire des gâteaux à ma banque vous
faites votre CV aura comme un
décollage de tank et ensuite celui qui gagnera gagnera
comme un voyage à euh j'ai un voyage à ihop
mais assurez-vous d'apporter votre passeport parce que
c'est  droit international
ah